ya entra en un segundo en funcionamiento
a causa de el coronavirus y el premier
yang castex reveló los detalles al
completo de las nuevas medidas
fisker ibiris axel ea ya que la
transmisión del virus se está acelerando
nosotros tenemos que acelerar también la
meta de sencilla proteger la salud de
nuestros ciudadanos al romper con todos
los medios posibles con la espiral de la
pandemia
tunuyán las es por eso que el presidente
ha decidido imponer un aislamiento de
nivel nacional comenzando desde la
medianoche del jueves hasta el 1º de
diciembre las principales restricciones
son las siguientes las personas tendrán
que permanecer en sus hogares y sólo se
les permite salir si tienen una
justificación para ello
esto incluye compra de bienes esenciales
llevar a los niños al colegio acudir a
citas médicas asistencia de urgencia
para un familiar y ejercitarse una hora
al día en un margen de un kilómetro
sobre su residencia cualquiera que
abandone su hogar tendrá que tener un
documento justificando su salida y puede
ser revisado por la policía a diferencia
del confinamiento decretado en marzo las
escuelas seguirán estando abiertas
mientras que las universidades
cerradas los cafés bares y restaurantes
tendrán que cerrar al ser negocios no
esenciales supermercados farmacias
ópticas talleres y las banderías
continuarán funcionando en lo que se
refiere a las medidas sobre el trabajo a
todos aquellos que puedan realizar sus
labores desde casa se les solicitará
hacerlo salvo dificultades técnicas los
servicios del sector público estarán
abiertos al igual que los lugares de
culto pero celebraciones como las bodas
estarán limitadas a pequeños grupos
nadie puede entrar a francia desde otros
países de la unión europea salvo
circunstancias especiales unas
condiciones que llevaron a más de uno en
la noche del jueves a buscar salir de
parís rumbo a otros destinos fuera de la
capital para pasar el nuevo aislamiento